hi I'm Evan Carmichael your friends and
all things entrepreneurship today I'm
doing another one of my fiber gates
where I review somebody's website and
give them some advice and tips so
today's web site comes in is blogging
for cash now blogspot com best viewed
with chrome or firefox i use chrome so
it looks like we're good to go this is
from charles so let's go check out the
site this is it now before even looking
at it i'm not a huge fan of the blogspot
domain name and i think you should be
avoided as much as possible a couple
reasons one a lot of people use it for
spammy websites and so as soon as
somebody sees a blogspot domain in the
search results I really discounts it and
the you're going to decrease your
click-through percentage you're not
going as many people clicking on it
because they're used to it being more of
a spammie type of site and you do not
build in an asset here so you're not
going to get as much benefit if you ever
want to sell the cell the website sell
your business pass it on to somebody
else your value will go down because you
don't actually own the blogspot a lot
more value comes from owning your own
domain name and so you're building up
somebody else's asset instead of
building up your own which you know
isn't as great as it could be so
something that gets something to
consider okay let's get into this
website so blogging for cash now the the
name itself sounds a little scammy so
your challenge here is going to be
showing that you are reputable site and
making people believe in you I would
probably invest a little bit in making
this design a little bit better the logo
looks like it's just been written on you
can go to place like 99 designs and for
200 bucks get a really nice professional
logo done that you can be really proud
of and the design of the site is just
okay very basic I would look at
switching this to a wordpress design
it's the same level difficulty are
probably easier to post which is great
and it's also gives you a lot of themes
that you can upload for free a lot that
that are really nice or you can pay a
little bit of money you know 100 bucks
or less for premium theme but you can
get a really nice one for free as well
and just get that updated there so next
this is maybe a little too long your one
paragraph kind of intro i'd like to see
maybe underneath here one sentence
explain what it is that you're all about
and and this is maybe cut up into couple
sentences couple paragraphs are your
bold some key some key words you're not
making people read as much but let's
click down to we have so we have an ad
here and I'd here I guess this is a big
I so is this it's basically all odds I
guess for different make money types of
programs and so it's probably not gonna
keep people on your website very long
there's not a lot of or any value add
content so this is a hard website to
drive people to and when people do come
to the site they're not going to stick
because it's just basically ad after ad
after ad now what I would do to make
this better entities for you to get a
better result is one as I said move to
WordPress put it on your own domain name
make it look a little more professional
with a logo in a nice design to make it
personal so who is this person who's
recommending these programs who are you
put a picture of yourself explain why
you're doing this why did you start this
website what your goals are no talk a
little bit a little bit about yourself
and post some updates that kind of
personal connection will make people
want to sign up with you if you look at
the guys for making the money selling
these kinds of programs there guys like
John Chow like you mentioned here
because people like to buy from these
kinds of people so you could be the next
John Chow right show your face explain
what you're up to you don't necessarily
need to have as big a following as he
does but it's an opportunity to brand
yourself and be seen as an expert and
when he goes out and recommend something
people end up buying because they like
him know him trust him or when he
creates his own product here as well so
that could be an opportunity for you
down the line but for now you want to
start building a connection with your
audience show your face do some videos
explain why you got started what you
hope to accomplish and put some updates
and so people will say hey I want to be
like this guy and will hopefully take
the next step and do sign up with some
of the programs that you're recommending
especially if you're using any of these
programs that's the best way to do it
because it shows that you're getting
benefit from it and we'll explain why
you like it and the more likely to want
to sign up for it as well the next thing
is to do some kind of review so all I
see here is an odd so if I'm looking at
this page just just looks like an ad and
doesn't say anything about this program
you don't even know what it's called and
so if I click here I've been looking at
the bottom left hand corner it directs
me to a different website and so I'm not
being told why this is a good program or
not so if you actually did some work to
review a program maybe got it for free
and said I want to review your program
and explain the pros and cons that will
add a lot more value and you know give
you some content for the website that
can help drive some traffic but also
give you some conversions of some sales
coming in for you because you've done a
accurate honest review of what's good
and what's bad about the different
programs that you're showing off here
finally I probably do some kind of
newsletter to capture leads and
follow-up so somebody hits this website
their only option is to click on an ad
and maybe sign up for whatever program
or bounce which is not a great way to do
it it's like meeting somebody at a bar
and saying will you marry
it's all or nothing and most people
won't do that on the first visit you
have to get to know them let them trust
you and a great way to build a
relationship is through a newsletter so
if you gave away some free kind of ebook
or download and they trust you to get
into their email list then you have a
way to follow up with them and give them
value ID information not just sales
content explain again why you're doing
this what you hope to accomplish things
that you've learned lessons that can
help them and start getting them to know
you a little bit better so that when you
do promote something they're going to
want to sign up and be the first ones on
board because you said it was a good
idea so those are my initial thoughts
looking at this website a lot of room
for improvement but a lot of opportunity
ahead as well I think if you did a good
job running it good luck with it keep me
posted I want to see some changes and
I'd love to to see you know where you go
with it for those of you watching I'd
love to hear we have to think give it a
thumbs up below it makes me want to do
more videos and if you have a comment
about this video or about your own
business feel free to leave it in the
comments section below I always check
those out and look forward to hearing
from you thank you and I'll see you on
the next episode
you